what
okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of
uh history of science and technology q
a so i have a number of questions that
uh got left over from last time
there's one from ein here about neural
networks
and uh when did neural nets overtake
more traditional optimization approaches
such as nonlinear programming
why did that happen what was the story
well let's see
maybe we should talk a little bit about
the history of neural networks
and uh that whole story
so neural networks
are sort of inspired by things about the
brain
and i think the um uh the first question
was
you know brains do thinking people have
known that forever
people were a little bit unclear exactly
you know even what part of the body did
the thinking back in antiquity
but uh you know eventually it became
clear brains do thinking
now the question is how do they do
thinking what is involved in thinking
what uh how do we make sort of a a uh
how do we make a mechanical way of doing
the same kind of thing
and a lot of development was done on on
thinking about
computation as something a bit like
thinking and so for example
in the 1940s 1950s even you know
whenever computers were being referred
to they were always talked about often
talked about as
you know giant electronic brains things
like this
um so there was sort of a a close
correlation
between the idea of thinking and the
idea of
of computing digital computing things
like that
i would say that the um uh
the thing that um um
uh you know in terms of how do brains
work
the um uh sort of a very key part of
that story was
realizing what are the components of
brains that
actually are the the you know that
do things and that had to do with
understanding neurons
and nerve cells and these long spindly
things that we find throughout our
brains
that are the the stuff that presumably
makes our brains
able to do what our brains can do and i
guess a a key figure in that whole story
was romani
cajao a spanish anatomist around 1900
who was the person who figured out who
managed to make
very very nice drawings
of of the structure of brains and of
particularly of neurons and brains
and i think one thing was important for
that is the whole issue of
of staining cells like you know i i have
to say i'm
way too squeamish to have ever seen a
brain in the flesh so to speak
um but uh they're they're um
you know they're kind of uh they're just
full of stuff and it's not clear you
know to say oh there's this cell and
there's that cell they're a little bit
transparent it's hard to tell what's
going on
an important step was learning how to
stain biological tissues
in such a way things like golgi staining
where only a
some small fraction of cells turn purple
and that means
you can you can see you can kind of
trace out
what the pattern of of uh uh of
connections is
for a pattern the shape of a particular
cell so that was the romani cachal thing
around 1900
and so then the question was sort of how
uh given this
idea that there were kind of these long
spindly things
that looked a little bit like wires that
were throughout the brain
what did that mean about how brains
actually worked well in the early parts
of the 20th century
all sorts of electrical machinery was
getting produced and there were things
tons of things full of wires you know
phone networks
uh telephone exchanges lots of things
full of wires and it kind of
felt like all this electrical circuitry
was somehow a little bit like what was
happening in brains and of course people
had known
that nerve cells were fundamentally
electrical they'd known that ever since
people like volta
had uh you know done those those
terrible experiments with frog legs and
things
where you where you put an electric
shock in and that causes the
the muscles to to activate and so on
people had known that nerves were
fundamentally an electrical
kind of thing so you know one had this
idea that
you know brains are full of wires and
they're sort of electrical kinds of
things and they have these machines
that are full of wires somehow there's
something in common between those
and i i guess um
the uh sort of the the the key
uh a key contribution to that was warren
mcculloch and walter pitts
in 1943 i think
um uh wrote this paper
about kind of a a sort of a mathematical
way to think about
what might be going on with all these
sort of connections and wire-like things
in brains
and trying to make that i should explain
that
that one thing that had happened was
that
people had initially just been building
electrical machinery just
you know build it in a pure engineering
kind of way and then there's sort of
more principled approach
to engineering and to making electric
circuits and for example claude shannon
had pointed out
that you could use boolean algebra to
think about switching circuits that you
could have a sort of mathematical
formalism
to describe switching circuits um and to
describe electrical machinery
and that kind of fed into well let's try
and use that kind of thing to describe
the
sort of electrical machine that we have
that is our brains
and um the at the time
was sort of another tradition which was
the psychiatry
psychology type tradition um and you
know
psychiatry was particularly big and
psychoanalysis and so on particularly
big
in the 1940s and 1950s particularly i
think in the u.s
um and uh so kind of the at the time
sort of that was a
a top field that was kind of the the i
don't know might be the machine learning
or the cryptocurrency of its day
was sort of psychiatry and i was a very
popular
sort of best and brightest type field
and um
one member of that um
so there will be conferences there was
also this kind of tradition of
cybernetics
that was cybernetics is this kind of the
idea is
how do you control uh things machines
animals all these kinds of things how
what is the what is the mechanism for
controlling them how do they get
to do what they want to do and do it in
sort of a
a way where there is a an automatic
control loop which says
you know if it's if things are uh
you know how do you how do you arrange
to pick something up by sort of
controlling you
you see with your eyes where your
fingers are moving you can feel
something about what's happening to the
object you do this how to
how does that whole sort of feedback
loop work and um
in in world war ii there had been um
a bunch of work done uh for example at
mit at the radiation
uh no the laboratory for electronics
at mit um and various other places
on um on kind of uh autonomous control
how do you get things
to be able to with just an electric
circuit so to speak
be able to do these kinds of things that
seem to require
control of various kinds i mean the
extreme versions might be things like
riding a bicycle and not having it fall
over you know you have to have
this sort of mechanism of oh you you're
tipping over a bit
now uh you know move this way to make
the bicycle right
one of the big successes was an
anti-aircraft gun
um that had a kind of predictive control
mechanism
where because you kind of have to uh
let's see i think i guess the main point
is you have to shoot a little bit ahead
of the thing you're shooting at
because it will have moved by the time
you get there and there was sort of a
feedback mechanism for having that work
and and that was um so this
field that uh uh was initially kind of
the control of things
humans machines whatever um got called
cybernetics after the greek term
uh kubernetes which is a helmsman of a
ship
um and that was kind of where the whole
cyber thing came from
and uh the kind of at least the the big
uh
sort of uh promoter of that area was
norbert weiner
who was a person at mit um
who uh sort of started off as a pure
mathematician was kind of a
math prodigy type um but had kind of
gone
into much more of this apply mathematics
to lots of kinds of things in particular
to this problem of autonomous control
and in the early days of cybernetics
cybernetics was a very um
kind of high concept sort of ai-ish like
field um and uh particularly in the
1950s in the early 1950s
there were a series of uh macy
conferences
uh i guess funded by the the macy's
department store
folk um that tried to sort of collect
together
um all sorts of people from variously
from
uh some of the then popular fields like
psychiatry anthropology
together with the math people and so on
and so you know people like margaret
mead
anthropologist was was a fixture at
these kinds of things
along with a variety of other people one
of the fixtures there was warren
mcculloch
who was a psychiatrist based in the
chicago area
um i think he worked at uh
a psychiatric hospital in in chicago
um and uh also had some connection with
the university of
uh was it uh university of chicago or
um university of illinois in chicago i'm
not sure um
that um uh
as a as a kind of a sort of psychiatrist
interested in theoretical kinds of
things
so it was uh it was it was uh warren
mcculloch
who sort of wrote the key paper sort of
pulled together the key
uh um notion of let's um
uh let's take sort of this electrical
machinery idea
let's take a little bit of what we know
about how brains actually work
and let's try and make sort of a
theoretical model for what's going on
he was helped by a chap called walter
pitts who was
um kind of a a young
uh kind of um uh math um
math sort of prodigy kind of person
who'd wound up um
uh trying to remember the full story but
had uh
wound up you know didn't didn't go
through any fancy education system
and came from a not terribly advantaged
background and wound up
just sort of hanging out around
university of chicago
and um ended up being sort of
uh pulled in by warren mcculloch as an
assistant
um to uh uh to him
in a sort of mathematical assistant in
the things he was doing and so this key
paper
1943 i think um by um laura mcculloch
and walter pitts
on on sort of the the theoretical
framework
for thinking about how sort of a wire
connected kind of
thing with neurons um might be able to
work
and so that um uh that
was a um uh sort of a key moment it sort
of brought together
the tradition of things like turing
machines these sort of idealized models
of computation
with things that might be brain-like so
that um kind of started a whole bunch of
research
and there were all sorts of questions
about how would brains actually work and
how would memories actually people had
the idea that memories were stored in
the synapses
between nerve cells the connections the
places where nerve cells connect
and that seems to be what's what's
really true and one knows quite a bit
about the mechanism now
but um uh there was sort of a question
about what would the rules be by which
memories would be
formed and there was a uh heb had this
whole uh
idea about uh you know if if nerves have
been
if two nerves had fired together then
there would be this kind of rule that
says strengthen the connection between
those
those nerves and so on and this whole
idea of weights and this whole notion
that basically they're a discrete set of
firings of nerve cells
and and so on that was all in the kind
of mcculloch pets paper
and by that time by the way it was also
known that their from electrical
recordings of nerve cells
it was known that there would be that
with these sort of moments where a nerve
cell was firing where it would
would uh uh release a kind of electrical
pulse
that could go on to other nerve cells
and so on so that that whole notion of
discrete firings
weights you know a nerve cell connected
to many others with different kinds of
weights associated with synapses
that was all kind of known by that
period of time
okay so then people said great there's a
formal model
well now we can start actually
implementing that let's make machines
that do this
and um as they tried to do that and in
the 1950s i guess
there were some early kind of ocr
optical character recognition
approaches um that uh made use of early
neural nets and strangely
uh in that's still how optical character
recognition is done
but at the at the beginning it was just
sort of recognized one of ten digits
type thing
um and um and then by the 1980s it got
to be use those methods
to recognize all the letters of the
english alphabet or something like this
but i'm kind of getting ahead of myself
there so
what happened was there was some sort of
early kind of
very simple neural net kinds of things
like marvin minsky for example
uh built this thing called the snark
which was some kind of hardware
uh neural net thing that was done in
what was that what was the early 50s i
think
um and a variety of other
initiatives like this people observed
all kinds of things they observed for
example that
in these nerve cell in these sort of uh
electrically created nerve cell type
things
that you would get sometimes you would
get behavior you could understand
sometimes you'd get random noise
but they failed to kind of understand
really dig into understanding what that
random noise is
they might have discovered some of the
things i found out about things like
cellular automata
many years later if they kind of dug
into that but they didn't at the time
they were really concentrating on how
can we make these kind of artificial
neural networks do something useful
so then there's a guy called frank
rosenblatt at cornell who um
uh uh kind of tried to develop this
theory
and this approach to sort of simplifying
how neural nets might work he developed
these things called perceptrons
and perceptrons are kind of one layer
neural networks
and so perceptrons were something you
could readily construct
out of electrical circuitry and you
could also do
quite a bit of analysis of how they
worked well that was good and that was
bad
because then um marvin minsky and
seymour pappet uh ceo papa was better
known
i think as the creator of logo which was
a computer language for kids it turned
into scratch and things like that
but he was also a person interested in
in kind of um
uh mathematical thinking of various
kinds and he and marvin minsky
wrote this book about perceptrons and in
this book the main thing they did was to
show that
what a perceptron does it takes these
inputs it's just sort of one layer
neural network
what it does is equivalent to essential
linear algebra it's equivalent to just
saying
uh it's equivalent to just defining kind
of a hyperplane
in um uh in some space of variables and
saying
things on the left that's uh you know
that's classified as an a things on the
right that's classified as b
okay so that people then realized oh
these perceptrons really don't do
anything non-trivial
and so it's like okay neural nets forget
neural nets not going to do anything
interesting
uh you know as uh you know minsky and
papa prove that neural nets don't do
anything interesting
it's the kind of thing that happens in
the history of science people
show something and then but it's
actually not the right thing
and then everybody says oh yeah we
proved that doesn't work
uh it's kind of an unfortunate kind of
herd mentality in the history of science
but it happened in this case
uh even despite at least in later years
those authors because i knew them both
um saying no no that really wasn't what
we meant
but in any case that was the takeaway
that people had so for years
kind of killed work on neural networks
then
in 1980 yeah 1980-ish
a group of people started getting
interested in neural nets again they're
kind of
largely from the neuroscience side and
talking a lot about parallel distributed
processing pdp
and there were a group of people um
uh let's see um
including um uh jeff hinton
uh my friend terry sanowski and
uh mcclelland and maybe one other person
and i'm forgetting and i apologize
to that person because i knew all of
these people um
uh but there was a group of people who
were really interested in kind of more
on the neuroscience side although
most of them came from kind of
physically backgrounds but we're
interested in neuroscience kinds of
things
of you know could one think about brains
as a sort of parallel distributing
processing system
and um back at that time they started
having um
conferences and summer schools and so on
um about that
another person who was in that picture
was present called john hopfield
who was a physicist who had worked at
bell labs and was
by then working at caltech and um john
hopfield
uh sort of came up with a simplified
neural net model and
basically uh that involved had a very
sort of mathematically simple way
to do training and which had the feature
that it could sort of
you could at least mathematically think
of it as recognizing things
and in particular that sort of connected
with the idea of attractors
that was an idea that had become popular
from dynamical systems theory
the idea that uh it's kind of like
imagine you have a landscape and you
have water rain falling on that
landscape
and you the question is where will that
rain flow to
and there'll be some watershed where the
rain flows either in this direction or
in that direction you know
like in the u.s it's either going to
flow to the atlantic or to the pacific
and there's sort of a watershed between
those between the rain is
actually probably that's not that's an
oversimplification obviously
but you can you can see that they'll be
sort of you have this mountainous
landscape and the water is going to
collect on sort of once
one valley side or the other valley side
and that's kind of what the idea of an
attractor
is you can think about it more
mechanically it's kind of like something
where
you have a a thing and it's either going
to roll down in one direction roll down
in the other direction
it's going to end up in one stable state
or another stable state
i could talk another time maybe about
some uh kind of the the
whole chaos theory and the idea of
strange attractors
but for the purposes of neural networks
these were attractors that were fixed
points
where it's just like okay i recognize
it's an a or okay i recognize it's a b
but there was a basin of attraction this
kind of set of
uh set of possible inputs that were
consistent with it being an a and
consistent with it being a b and if we
think about that
just in terms of printed characters it
might be well that's an a but it's got a
bunch of extra
pixels and the a has been distorted in
this way in that way but it's still in
the basin of attraction for
an a and if it's been if it's something
that kind of looks like a b
it's still in the basin of attraction
for a b and so the idea of something
like hopfield's very simple setup
was it was something where you could see
it was like a dynamical systems-like
attractor
we could set it up to say yes it's going
to sort of
with this class of inputs it's going to
roll down to being an a
this class remember it's going to roll
down to being a b i mean i i was
uh caltech at that time or others around
1980 1981
and um i did a bunch of simulations
trying to reproduce what what um
what hot people have found i actually
had a very hard time reproducing
uh some of what was what was being said
there um i it was quite
sensitively dependent on a lot of
details about exactly how you thought
about doing the updates on the neurons
and
and all this kind of thing but in any
case it was nice because it was kind of
a mathematically tractable model
that went beyond the perceptron kind of
idea and sort of the key notion here
which uh sort of got got developed later
was this idea of hidden units
that you would have the input layer you
would have the output layer the thing
where it
you know where a particular neuron would
sort of light up if it was an a or it
was a b
but then you would have these layers of
hidden units in between
and then the key idea that emerged at
that time is this idea of back
propagation
the idea of okay if you gave the wrong
result
how do you propagate back the error
the the the the fact that you got the
wrong result and how do you change the
weights
to do sort of neural net training so
that was slowly starting to be
understood back propagation was a big
thing in the early 80s
um it was sort of a a thing people
talked about
but um uh but it didn't really
didn't really catch on now people were
actually using neural nets
um in uh for industrial purposes
neural nets were used in uh
as a way to do optical character
recognition for example and famously
they were used uh i think it was the
project of bell labs by jan lacun
and some other people um that
was for reading checks you know reading
off the
the written characters uh and checks
um and and it worked and you know with a
limited number of possibilities you know
like 10
10 digits or something um you could make
a neural net that did that
uh don't know exactly how those neural
nets were created and trained but they
were tweaked
to the point where yes they did a pretty
good job of distinguishing between ten
kinds of things
okay so people really the field of
neural nets
was pretty dead in the sort of academic
type world
uh there wasn't a lot of uh you know oh
yes neural nets are going to be a big
thing people
people did work on them but it was kind
of like oh this isn't really going to
work
and then there was another side of the
neuroscience people
who were well the the neural nets that
people do for
for sort of uh actual pattern
recognition
uh really aren't like the brain the
brain doesn't have the mechanisms
that are like those pattern recognition
networks things like hopfield's network
involved taking you know outer products
to matrices and things
that were just seemed like completely
different from the way that actual
neurons and brains worked
and so that wasn't that wasn't really a
there was a
sort of a set of people who were doing
in a sense
um uh kind of mathematically informed
neuroscience but they really thought of
themselves as doing neuroscience kinds
of things and
separate from what was going on there
okay so meanwhile
there had been sort of a more
traditional approach to pattern
recognition
um where you would extract certain
features
using image processing but pretty pretty
much using linear algebra
to do to say okay let's where's an edge
in an image okay we can find an edge in
an image by saying
uh you know there's a we just look at
differences between uh
color levels of pixels and where there's
a big sharp difference that's where
there's an edge
and there had been a um uh there have
been various attempts
to um uh so so actual pattern
recognition
in the practical world was done using a
whole bunch of tricks like this like you
want to find roads in a satellite image
okay there's this particular filter
where you look at pixels you know this
set of pixels and you
you have these um uh gabor filters and
things like this these are
and things where you're taking sort of a
convolving a gaussian with
with an image and you're saying you know
arrange it this way arrange it that way
and sort of i i did a bunch of those
things we did a bunch of those things i
i imagined actually
um back in the in the mid 2000s so to
speak before 2010
i imagined that um uh we would be able
to make
an image recognition system where we
specifically had sort of curated
filters that would be this is the one
for picking out windows this is the one
for picking out
rhodes is the one for picking out this
that and the other there was a famous
one of that type for picking out faces
that was just a completely sort of hacky
weird filter thing where you're just
looking at pixel combinations and this
and that
and it was a successful way of picking
out faces and it was the standard way to
do it
and that was the way things were up
until
well around 2000 uh 2011 2012
was that the the way of doing like image
processing
was you just used kind of um these hacky
filter-like things
there was a an annual competition that
was an image image analysis competition
and you know
the best hacks won for years
okay so then and meanwhile neural nets
nothing much was happening with neural
nets it was a niche field
and um uh you know there were some
industrial applications but they were
not
widely kind of uh didn't widely spread
out into academia
weren't really widely known there they
were just like oh yeah that's an
engineering solution
not really that's something that we can
sort of do theoretical work
on okay so meanwhile people like jeff
hinton
continued to sort of think about uh deep
neural nets
and multi-layer things and continue to
think about how back propagation could
be used all those kinds of things
um but didn't work it wasn't really a
practical system
i don't know the full details of this
story but the the thing that was really
the
the breakout moment was this thing
called alexnet
i think this happened in 2011. so i
think a graduate student who um
was trying to run a deep learning uh
neural net training process on a bunch
of images
and they you know had it run
and then they just left it running for a
couple of months by mistake
and you know after they come back in a
couple of months it's like um what what
does the training consist of it consists
of going through this loop of doing you
know
uh do the uh you know
you know try and recognize an image oh
you got it wrong do back propagation
from the error et cetera et cetera et
cetera gradually try and tweak these
weights
okay so they just left it running and
and
didn't pay any attention to it and then
fortunately before they you know having
realized oh it's just been running for
two months
it's like well let's actually try it and
see whether it works and
by golly it did and what happened
then was the big thing happened i guess
what was it late 2011 maybe early 2012
was that network was entered
in the sort of annual image recognition
competition and it won and so this was
the
this was the first time that a sort of
not non-tweaked non-hacked
thing that came from the neural net
world had been that successful
in in pattern recognition for images
now uh you know the big thing was
yes people had done digit recognition
from a long time ago
people had done uh you know
sort of letters of the alphabet
recognition also from quite a long time
ago
but you know there are about five or ten
thousand picturable nouns in english you
know
cats and dogs dogs and tables and chairs
and so on and the question is
can you do a good job of recognizing ten
thousand different kinds of things
and that was something that had not
scaled at all in the kind of period when
it was sort of
engineering uh you know when it was
before this kind of before there was
sort of a systematic way of of training
neural nets
with with deep learning and so 2012-ish
uh sort of
this really started to take off and it
started to be kind of the big rumor of
silicon valley
is deep learning's been made to work
people are going to solve everything
with deep learning
and um what happened theoretically well
it's sort of interesting actually
the it was one of these cases where the
harder problem was actually easier than
the easier problem
what do i mean by that people have
thought oh we're going to try and train
these neural nets it's like this
complicated landscape
you have to sculpt this landscape we
have to define where the attractor
basins are
all that kind of thing it's all a very
complicated thing let's start off with
the toy problems
oh the toy problems are actually really
quite hard and
it's really difficult to do all that
training and so on but then turns out
when you have the more difficult problem
with more degrees of freedom more
dimensions etc etc etc
it actually somehow gets a bit easier
because you can kind of
bash the um uh you you kind of don't get
the big issue is
when you do kind of gradient descent
when you try and figure out
where is the optimal uh value of this or
that parameter
you can get stuck in a local minimum and
you can't get out
well the chance of getting stuck in a
local minimum is
lower if you are in this complicated
landscape where there's often a way out
than it is in the simple landscape where
oops you got stuck in this kind of
you know crater and there's just no way
out i should have explained there were
a lot of other ideas about some kind of
boltzmann machines and a lot of
kind of discussion about the role of
noise and getting you out of these
local minima is this technique called
simulator kneeling
widely used to kind of that was a
technique that was invented around
1980-ish by i'm thinking scott
kirkpatrick and some other people who
were trying to do
things like microprocessor design um
where
the again it was this question of how
can you make solve this optimization
problem
or you get stuck in the circle minimum
let's pretend
that uh there's some heat that's being
added that's giving you a certain amount
of randomness
let's use that randomness to break you
out of the local minimum
and potentially get you into the more
global minimum and then then there's a
whole elaborate thing just like
annealing
where you anneal a material to try and
make it form a better crystal
um there was a whole elaborate story of
what would be the annealing schedule
and the optimal temperature and so on
and some of those kinds of things have
have shown up in different forms in
modern neural network methods
um but that was kind of the the back
history of that kind of thing
but so then in um uh
you know and i should say that this
whole idea about how do you
solve how do you do global optimization
how do you given a function given some
complicated thing where they're lots of
ups and downs
how do you how do you find the um uh the
optimal
uh solution to that that had been a
problem
that there wasn't really good solution
to i mean to talk a little bit about
that problem
so so one of the things that had
happened in um
uh you're trying to solve a constraint
you're trying to say
i've got these inequalities x plus y is
greater than 10
z minus x is less than three et cetera
et cetera et cetera
can you solve those constraints and can
you optimize
the value of x plus 10 y plus 7z
subject to those constraints that
particular type of problem
uh really kind of jumped into importance
around the time the second world war um
because it was
very much involved in kind of logistical
calculations
of you know how many this is do you need
with this constraint on the number of
uh this kind of supply that you're going
to have how do you make this and how do
you make that
and that turned into this whole field of
operations research
that really got big in in world war ii
um on the on the uh sort of allies side
it never really took off on the um on
the kind of access side
which means that i think there isn't
even a word for operations research at
least last i checked
in in german and japanese for example um
so it was a thing that
really took off at that time and then
operations research
um this idea of of uh um the
the key discovery was this thing called
the simplex algorithm
which is basically tells you kind of
that that if there's a solution it's
always in the corners and there's a
particular algorithm for finding it
um uh oh my gosh
bellman was that the person who invented
that am i getting that wrong
um i was invented no
danzig george danzig that's right um
1940
boy you see this is a very challenging
thing because i you know if i could look
all this stuff up it's a lot easier but
i'm choosing not to do that i think
i think 1946 but i might be wrong about
the the um the date of the simplex
algorithm
but anyway this that was a way of
dealing with linear inequalities
and that got very big in um uh
kind of the industrial base in the u.s
with general motors you know being a
a big place and um people like robert
mcnamara was sort of the
an example of a person who later became
secretary of defense during the vietnam
war
um but he had been involved in in sort
of the um
uh the kind of the the up-teching
of manufacturing in places like general
motors
using methods like the methods of
operations research
that had come out of world war ii and
using things like the simplex algorithm
and linear programming so okay so that
was sort of a big thing
and then the question was what about the
non-linear case that was all fine
when everything was linear where we were
just adding things up linearly
um the nonlinear case well the nonlinear
case was hard
and eventually in modern times you know
in the last probably 10
15 20 years this uh convex optimization
which is a particular convex functions
that's finally been solved and that's
been quite important for
robotics and lots of other purposes that
that finally got solved in a non-linear
case got solved but for a long time
it was kind of the linear program in
case they've been solved and by the way
another thing that was some
sort of a big deal was that in principle
the simplex algorithm
can be exponentially slow and there was
a thing uh the comic or algorithm i
think was the the thing was that was
discovered in the
1980s at bell labs was at least in
principle an algorithm
that allowed you to go much faster for
even the bad cases of linear programming
most cases of linear programming weren't
that bad but there were bad cases
and that was a matter of yes people
could say yes you could really do this
non-linear optimization was really kind
of a
a black box and what would happen is
there'd be these groups that would say
we would have some magic method for
doing non-linear optimization i remember
when mathematica first came out in in
1988
i remember we would have all the time
people be contacting us you know
i'm a professor i've been working on
this for a long time i've got this magic
method for doing global optimization
it's like how can this possibly work you
know you've got
some collection of functions and you've
got um
and you're you're trying to find the
place where they're the minimum
and you know it's like it was all black
box hackers so to speak
and uh and for a long time i really
resisted having
a you know a kind of a systematic
function in mathematica for example
that would claim to find a global
minimum because i said you just can't do
it
well okay what finally happened
um as a result of the whole sort of
neural net development
was well yeah you still can't really do
it but there are a bunch of pretty
decent ways to
sort of approximate that that are what
neural net training effectively is doing
and you know when we first train neural
nets so we
we the first kind of serious thing we
did with neural nets was um 2014 is that
right
i think so um was an image identifier
still a website you still find it
imageidentify.com
it's the thing that fed into the
function image identify
and so for example when we trained that
we
used a few million images that had been
foraged from the web we used some um
um uh thing called imagenet
um that have been sort of foraged by by
faith maybe in some other people
um the uh uh
that that was sort of one one source and
we had a variety of other sources
of um uh of of training images
and then we had we had a few million of
those and then we let the thing train
uh for a few months of cpu time and that
was kind of the order of magnitude that
was needed at that time
to make a decent image identifier i
think we were very early to the
to the story of having kind of a a a
a directly usable image identification
system
um it uh you know subsequently a lot of
things which i maybe shouldn't talk
about here
develop to do with transfer learning
where you're able to sort of bootstrap
one uh one kind of um
you're able to make use of training
you've already done to be able to
identify features
that you will then use to to uh make it
faster to
to learn more stuff and it's probably
very similar to the way that brains
actually work
so in any case i'm not i think i lost
track of what the
original um um
uh question was here but it was about
the sort of taking off neural net
uh technology and i mean what's happened
over the last
um basically seven or eight years
is uh sort of a big development of yes
you can make bigger and bigger fancier
and fancier neural nets
um there are uh there have been
different uh
phases of that development i mean
there's somewhere it's all about the
architecture of the neural net
convolutional neural nets
a little bit like cellular automata
things where you're actually laying out
networks and
laying out neurons kind of in space like
they would be in an image
or you know transformer nets has been a
popular thing recently
um or you know these various kinds of
memory
networks with with some memory lstms uh
recurrent neural networks things like
that uh
different different uh sort of periods
of development
of of sort of the complexity of the
actual neural nets themselves
and um there's kind of a there's the
development of the neural nets
themselves as the development of
training
sets for the neural nets and how big the
training sets are and the preparation of
more training sets and so on and then
there's the question of application
areas
and what sort of happened over the years
is that different application areas have
sort of come into scope
and then been captured and so for
example the earliest one
was object recognition and images and uh
to get to
and really you know there's been gradual
improvement but basically
that one got solved in the
2015-2016-2017
type time frame and it's like yes there
are 10 000 kinds of things and you can
recognize them
you can feed in other kinds of things
you recognize them then there were
things
like uh um um
uh speech to text speech to text was
another big area
where what had been done in the past
was was all sort of specific
kind of hackery techniques maybe i
should talk about that one it's got an
interesting one
so the um uh
the question was you know how would you
recognize you know you've got speech
and what does speech consist of well at
the first level it's just a pure
stream of sound but then actual human
speech
you can break into these things called
formants if you look at a spectrogram
you know a frequency as a function of
time plot
you'll see that there are these uh you
know particular sounds like vowel sounds
have a characteristic way that the
frequency
changes over a period of a few
milliseconds as
as our vocal tracts move and so the the
idea
of sort of early speech recognition was
make a spectrogram-like thing
and then pick out these four months in
the spectrogram so pick out the aeiou
you know pick out the phonemes from
english and so on and
the question was how would you do that
and much like image processing it was
done
using a specific oh yeah let's get
something that picks out the
uh you know the gutturals let's pick
something that picks out this
picks out these different kinds of
phonemes and so on very specifically
done that way
and then that sort of made way for
another kind of approach which was a
little bit more training based
but where you were learning the phonemes
you were just learning
yes this is what this this phoneme in
english sounds like
and so in order to learn those kinds of
things you had to tag
large amounts of of speech with
uh you know this is what was being said
this is all the phonemes in it et cetera
et cetera et cetera and then you had to
figure out how to assemble those
phonemes into actual um
uh into actual words and so on and so
there were um several companies that
really got
far along one was company called dragon
systems in the
in the boston area that was sort of
happening in the
uh let's see late 1970s early 1980s
um that eventually became part of nuance
which is a company that sort of bought
up a large number of
of uh voice to text companies um
uh based and happens to be based in the
boston area
um then there was a big initiative for
example at ibm
on voice to text um interestingly what
happened there was
that there's a funny story i mean the
group of people worked on voice to text
made a lot of progress there
and then it ended up that a whole bunch
of those people uh
moved to this company called renaissance
technologies
which was a hedge fund started by jim
simons
i was a mathematician and
uh kind of one of their first cool ideas
for hedge fund hedge funds i think
always exists in a sequence of cool
ideas was to kind of use
the uh the sort of the methods of audio
processing
that people knew from the speech to text
work to do things like um
uh you know at the chicago board of
trade i guess chicago mercantile
exchange now
to actually listen to the sounds made by
the traders as they were jumping up and
down on the
on the trading floor to be able to
predict more quickly you know price
movements and commodities and so on
but that sort of went gave way to
generally used pattern recognition of
the kind that have been used in speech
processing
on uh finding signals in the market
and uh that's you know that's what's
fueled renaissance as a
as they i mean they have specific
methods but um uh you know that was kind
of the
the launch pad for a bunch of those
methods um came out of the sort of the
speech recognition
group at ibm but so they've been these
various different groups that had made
good progress in speech recognition but
it was all at the level of you know
let's pick out the formants let's find
these phonemes let's try and assemble
phonemes into actual words after that
very similar to what was done in optical
character recognition
um that's still actually necessary an
optical character recognition
is well is that really a plausible word
you know you've got these letters
there's some probability of error in
each letter
you know is the thing that that
combination of letters is that a
plausible word or not
and and so that was an important thing
in both those areas
okay so voice to text was really a thing
where it was done with sort of detailed
specific work
until probably i don't know
four years ago maybe now um when
really neural nets started taking off
and being able to do that and that had
to do with recurrent networks and
being able to deal with sequences of of
data coming in and so on
and what was realized in the end was
that end-to-end training where you just
say
here's the speech here's the text just
train on the whole thing don't bother
about breaking it into phonemes and
doing silence identification all that
kind of stuff just train on the whole
thing
and turns out there were some very big
data sets to train on because
for example there's closed captions that
are created for television programs
and things where you have the audio
signal and you also have the closed
caption that was created
by humans in that case at least back
then by humans
um and that was so so again maybe four
years ago so this transition happened
uh voice to text went from being really
hard to being kind of
doable in um in neural nets and you know
like handwriting recognition we're not
there yet
can't yet do handwriting recognition
properly with neural nets probably
soon you will be able to um you know
other areas
uh um well language translation is
another area
where that had been again a story a very
detailed careful work
where people had said we're going to do
language translation
by actually understanding how to parse
language a break it into some kind of
semantic units and do this and that
and then transform it to language b the
language translation and that was a
was sort of a big idea back in the early
1960s that was sort of a big initiative
in artificial intelligence
was this notion of being able to do
language translation um
and it didn't work uh it didn't work
very well
although there were a number of
companies that that developed
uh not not totally terrible actually i
shouldn't say it didn't work
it eventually by the 1980s or 1990s
there was fairly decent uh kind of
by hand crafted language translation
technology between a bunch of languages
but then again neural nets came on the
scene and they gradually got better and
better and at this point
just in the last for a year or so
they've started to be
pretty big neural nets that have pretty
good
uh language translation capabilities i
mean we're just about
to uh start and we have some i think in
our neural net repository
we're just about to to actually i think
in the in the upcoming version of our
language
um we'll have um a sort of built-in uh
language translation with neural nets
and and you know what's fueled that
in part is the availability you need
these training sets of
you know parallel texts in different
languages and you know the things like i
don't know the bible's been translated
into
a zillion languages and that's a small
piece of parallel text
but the uh the larger scale parallel
texts
come from well various kinds of places
like in the european union
uh you know every random regulatory
thing
translated all into all the languages of
the eu so you have a lot of parallel
texts
um that exist that are you know a little
bit maybe they're a little bit
on the on the side of uh legalistic
kinds of texts but those are
there's a parallel text between those
languages another big corpus
is for example computer manuals that's
sort of a consortium of computer
companies
that have pooled some of the different
translated
uh manuals to be used to sort of raw
material for translation
training so those are those are kinds of
things there but anyway i think that the
the story of you know these different
domains where you start to be able to
sort of
use neural nets to do things there have
been different ones coming online in the
course of years
i don't think that's going to go on
forever i think that there are these
sort of moments when you yes you can do
it now it's very much
like the the story of the use of things
like linear algebra
in uh being able to do computer graphics
there was before you could do
three-dimensional
you know 3d graphics and hidden surface
elimination all those kinds of things
in a reasonably uh sort of smooth way
and there's after
and that that was the transition that
took a few years but it didn't take that
long
and we're seeing the same kinds of
things with a bunch of these methods
that can be done with
the neural nets a sort of transition of
this domain this kind of workflow
gets to be possible and what typically
happens is you get to a certain point
it's like goes from being really
impossible
to being possible and then there's a
gradual tweaking gradual improvement
that takes
a larger number of years and sometimes
people say look
it's been so possible you know in the
last two years we've got so much
improvement
it's going to go all the way it's going
to get to 100 it doesn't typically
happen that way there's typically a very
long
tail because there's there's a lot of
detail that
that can't be filled in all right that
was a super long
um super long answer to that uh
question so um uh
let's see um
all right a lot of questions here
um
our memory is stored in the brain well i
i have to take that one just for a
second because
because there are clearly it's like is
all genetic
information stored in the dna well no
actually because you know there's also
the whole egg cell that comes along and
it has some information in it as well
uh likewise with um you know there's a
there's a certain amount of
memory that is stored elsewhere like for
example as we're well aware in this
pandemic
the immune system has a complicated uh
kind of
memory of its own that's relevant for
the operation of the immune system at
least
so it's not the case that all the things
that have been printed in one's lifetime
are stored in kind of uh you know memory
in
in the brain so to speak there are other
sort of imprints of things that happen
that exist
okay um
let's see
i'm looking at some different
questions here um
well i could talk about uh i noticed a
comment here from
from prutz bell labs the company that
developed c and unix
right yes that that's bright bell labs
is a
i mean sadly doesn't really directly
exist anymore but but um
i did some consulting at bell labs back
in the early 1980s so i can
i can say a little bit about its history
and and um what it was like at that time
i mean the phone company was
you know had been
uh you know phones developed in the
early part of the 20th century
uh for a while there were all these
separate phone companies you know there
was a
a local phone company everywhere that
was laying the wires for that particular
place
and then i guess was it jp morgan i
think it was
who um kind of tried to roll up
sort of all these phone companies into
sort of a single
you know just bought up all these local
phone companies and roll them all up
into what turned into a t
and so it became a big sort of monopoly
a phone company
and uh it had various kinds of
regulation that got imposed in the
i guess in the 40s and 50s and so on
that was kind of a popular
uh thing was you know let's have a
regulated monopoly
um and um but one of the things that
that did as often happens with
monopolies
is uh okay if you're the monopoly you
might as well do basic research because
you're going to be the only beneficiary
if you discover something really cool
to do with the way that um uh you can
um i don't know set up electronics for
electronic switching systems or
something like that
um then uh you
then then because you're the one you're
the sort of monopoly that has
that's going to be the place where any
sort of electronic switching system is
going to be deployed
then you will be the beneficiary of
basic research you do so
so lots of basic research got done about
labs the transistor was invented there
um uh by um
bardeen brattain and shockley um
the transistor of course went on william
shockley went on
to uh start shockley labs in california
which was some uh connected
to fairchild which was originally a
camera company
that got into the electronics business
and pretty much all the companies you
know the intels and motorolas and so on
they actually motorola was a slightly
different story but the
a lot of these silicon valley
microprocessor companies were the kind
of the
the the progeny of the kind of the the
fair children as people sometimes say of
silicon valley
um and that was a lot of that came out
of shockley labs i mean william shockley
became very unpopular later on by
espousing a bunch
of theories that had nothing to do with
semiconductors and and
uh and so on um but he had been a
uh a very um uh his his um
r d operation at chocolate labs have
been an impressive thing and that was
sort of
a spin-off from from bell labs but okay
so
so then uh bell labs
you know this long history of a very
successful
innovation and i remember when i was
there
the the sort of the central facility was
in murray hill new jersey
and it was sort of notable for the fact
that there's this giant building these
giant corridors
and um it's kind of like you imagine
bringing the competitors there and
saying
you know how can you compete with our r
d you know we have researchers
you know going as far as the eye can see
down this giant
you know giant this giant corridor and
it was a place that i think
took a very serious uh uh did a very
serious job of
of trying to train people to do uh r
d management so to speak and they would
take people who had done
been successful as researchers and say
okay now you're going to become a
manager
and they would give them training and
they would kind of uh help develop
sort of you know stay on topic but
nevertheless
you know stimulate innovation i i
remember they had a
lot of kind of very bureaucratic
practices like for example the typical
office
just had a um uh you know a tile
tiled floor but then if you became a
manager
you've got a carpeted floor and so
somebody would become a you know an
office would be you know somebody become
a manager
the people would come in overnight and
they'd lay down carpet if that office
got used by somebody who wasn't a
manager anymore
the carpet would just disappear
overnight um
there's kind of a you know a very
definite kind of
bureaucracy uh set up there but i also
remember that
um they oh they had all kinds of funky
things to do with r d management
like one of the one of the more bizarre
ones was um
uh they'd had trouble with with people
assigning patents to bella labs at some
point
they had been um uh there had to be a
consideration
for the assignment of patents and so
everybody who went to work at the labs
they would give them a dollar as the the
consideration that would be sort of the
hook
that would allow them to do these patent
assignment things i know some patent
lawyer was very proud of having figured
out that particular
scheme for for making that possible but
um
there was a group of bell labs that was
sort of a
i think in in some ways a spin out of
the um
of the electronic switching system
effort that was a computer group
it became and i i didn't see it at the
time when when this was happening but um
this was late 1970s there was a need
okay so the big issue was you're going
to make an electronic switching system
and um uh that's gonna switch you know
lots of phone calls and
and they would have the you know the
number five ess number six css number
seven i think each one went up by sort
of a factor of ten
in a number of lines that it could
switch and there were these techniques
that were
at first kind of hardware-ish techniques
for
um oh i don't know actually originally
there were these electro-mechanical
switches
where you would actually move wheels
around to connect this to that
i remember in england when i was a kid
one of the excuses when the phone system
stopped working was oh it got very cold
and the switches froze
um but uh you know then then that gave
way to sort of
time division multiplexing where you
would have these time slices and so on
and um uh that would be the way that you
would sort of connect
the sender to the receiver by saying you
get this time slice
and we're compressing the data um and
then expanding it on the other side
but um uh sort of the the big
um innovation uh with big sort of idea
was well let's just use a computer
to do all the switching stuff let's have
the electronic switching system be
controlled
by a general purpose computer okay well
if we're going to do that
how should that computer be set up what
operating systems should be running what
uh you know how should that be be built
and so that was that was what created
unix
um unix was a um uh okay so they've been
predecessor operating systems a thing
called multics
was a predecessor operating system it
got very complicated
unix was the the um uh the kind of uh
stripped down multics um and that was i
guess 1976
7 that kind of time frame originally the
pdp-11
which was a machi kind of a small
computer
kind of small sleek computer made by
digital equipment corporation
was i think the early target for um
for unix but there was also a a a pisa a
computer that had been made
inside the um uh the bell system what
was it called the 3b
something or other 3b2 i forget
but there was a there was a a special a
computer that had been constructed by
the bell system to be used for
electronic switching networks
and um that was uh that along with the
pdp 11
were the early targets of the of the
unix operating system
and ken thompson and dennis ritchie were
the people
who originally worked on the unix
operating system
and to make that operating system they
also needed a programming language
and the programming language that they
uh built c
was sort of a derivative so they've been
language called bcpl
i don't remember what bc stands for but
pl stands for programming language
that have been developed i think in
england and there's a language called b
that have been developed that was uh
came out of bcpl
and c was the next letter in the bcpl
sequence uh for for a programming
language
and so uh they had and they were very
much into the kind of minimalism of the
program now it's kind of interesting
dennis richie actually had done a phd
thesis in theoretical computer science
and had worked on these things called
register machines which were kind of
very minimal
kind of models of computation and that
kind of i think i think he took over
some of that sort of minimalism thinking
um into uh uh into the kind of design of
the c programming language
i remember um uh talking to dennis ricci
and and ken thompson um back when i
was uh hanging out a bit at bell labs
and um
i had was after i had developed my first
uh
computer language smp and um smp
one of its features was it had very
short command lanes for everything
a bit like unix and these guys were yeah
yeah
short command names that's the way to go
it's that's now of course at the time
there were different ergonomics because
a lot of people
who might use a a programming language
didn't know how to type
so that was a you know it made it it was
worthwhile to have it
you know a thing called grep a thing
called orc a thing that was a or cd
or ls or something and it made a you
know it was
really worthwhile to have that be short
typing and there wasn't the idea of auto
complete and all those kinds of things
wasn't really a thing
but um i don't think it was one of the
better decisions in snp to have short
command names
because it made programs absolutely
incomprehensible um
it's a little bit different if you have
a sort of an operating system where
you're going to be
using it interactively but again when
you get scripts it becomes
incomprehensible
but um so at the time
um the uh so that was sort of the
origination of
c as the language for unix and then
then kind of the the um um
it was a time when when bella labs
didn't really care much about
they didn't think there was a business
to be made in selling software so
they weren't going to so they just sort
of let's just give unix away
um and that was kind of the the the idea
there
now you could tell a little bit more
about that history and my
slight involvement in it um the uh
um well gosh i could um
uh another figure in this whole uh story
is a person called rob pike
who i've known for many years he was a
graduate student at caltech
in physics he was actually the person
who told me in 1978 he said
there's this cool new language called c
and it's the thing you should use for
everything
and i remember the the very first
program that i wrote and see
was a program for doing uh percolation
theory which is a
kind of statistical physics thing and i
think it was rob who said
you really should use recursion and
recursion works really well in c
in fortran which had been sort of the
standard scientific programming language
before that time
at that time recursion just didn't work
in fortran
um and uh so in c you could have all
this nice recursive algorithm and so on
and that's
my my first big programming language smp
was written in c in the end
but anyway rob pike um was
sort of agonizing about should he go on
in as a physics graduate student or
he had this opportunity to go work at
bell labs in um
in the unix uh uh group and should he go
off and do that
and and i was like i think i was very
unpopular
among my colleagues at caltech because i
was like yeah you should go work at bell
labs it's
you know that's a really happening place
and really exciting and
frankly the the you know this physics
stuff is you know
it'll be there even if you decide you're
not interested in that it'll still still
be there
so he went off to bell labs and um uh
uh did did a whole bunch of things there
but the sort of an interesting piece of
history
the first big project he did there was a
thing uh called the blitz terminal
along with um uh
bart lokenfe i think that was the name
of another person who worked
on it um the but the blit terminal
had the following idea it was a bitmap
terminal
where the it was kind of like a thin
client what we would today call a thin
client it was something where
there had been um uh you would you would
have all that nice
fancy graphic display locally
but the real computation was going on
remotely and it was kind of
partly sold to bell labs on the grounds
of look this is the way people are going
to use phones more
they're going to have another phone line
that they're going to use to connect
their blitz terminal to the central
computer
and do kind of um uh
and do the um uh and sort of do their
computing
um in this kind of client server mode
where there'd be this sort of thin
client
that would be working just locally and
uh and the real computation will be done
remotely
um it's like uh you know maybe you've
heard that heard that
idea again but back in those days so
this was around 1980
early to mid 1980 in 1983 that kind of
time frame
this was a quite some uh
it was a project that really the results
were very nice
i i know there was a there was an att
stockholders meeting where they were
demoing things to
the blit terminal and somehow rob pike
was involved in the scheme
where they would have um little little
bug-like creatures
kind of eat their way in from the side
of the screen like his big display
and it was showing text and then somehow
the things started getting eaten from
the side of the screen
which was kind of interesting because
people hadn't seen bitmap terminals
and it's like how can this possibly be
happening you know what is really going
on how could you have
you know this display of text because
before that time
you know terminals were just like
literally and they were crt
this this was still a cathode ray tube
display
um where you know previous to that it
had been you know just displaying
characters and the electron beam would
just go through
this uh you know metal sheet that had
little
sort of templates of a's and b's and c's
and so on in it
and that would be how you would make the
the pattern of an a or a b or a c
but a bitmap terminal it's like every
pixel is separately
you know switch on pixels numbers such
and such and make that black
and that's how you made the characters
and so the idea that you could have
something that sort of looked like a
piece of paper
was getting eaten away out by little
bugs which is like a
completely bizarre science fictiony
thing i'm sure there's a video of that
somewhere on the web
but um in any case the the bullet
terminal was
was really very technically interesting
a lot of a lot of work went into
figuring out
sort of how to buffer data so that you
would have a good experience on it and
so on
um but you know one of the challenges in
a place like bell labs and a bell system
att in general
it's a big company it does what it does
and one thing it didn't do
was sell computers and so uh
the the the sort of the challenge was
how would one get
you know to the point where they had
some kind of licensing arm western
electric
etc etc etc and um
it was all a big kind of very crunchy
process
to see you know how could this thing get
out in the world well meanwhile
another approach was this was the
approach of the kind of client server
approach the other approach was
make a workstation computer where there
was a bitmap display
but the processing was happening right
there in the computer now that hadn't
been possible because the intel 8086 for
example
wasn't as a microprocessor it wasn't
really powerful enough you'd need big
you know circuit boards with custom
chips on them and things like that
there was the motorola 68 000 that came
out in the maybe 82 or so
uh no it must have been earlier there
82-ish which was
sort of a more powerful microprocessor
but you could imagine sort of building
kind of a whole computer
just around this one microprocessor and
so
there were a number of efforts to do
that there was a company called apollo
and there was also a project at stanford
the stanford university network
project um particularly done by andy
bechtelsheim who's a graduate student
there
um and that project i think um uh
i think vaughn pratt who's a really
theoretical computer science person was
somehow also involved in that
but any case the the um uh
um the thing that um uh
that that happened was uh i remember
i i ran into andy bechtelsheim at
stanford probably in
81 or 82 and um
he had this computer that was in a
cardboard box
and had this display you know the
computer the chassis of the computer was
just a cardboard box they had this
display that was the stanford university
network
computer that uh then became a company
uh called sun microsystems um that was a
workstation company
so and and that company uh brought in
uh well the sort of first business
uh ceo of it was vinod koshler um
and uh was president called bill joy was
the person who wrote the vi
editor who was at berkeley who'd written
the vi editor for unix
and he sort of joined as the as the
software person
so i happened to be at this dinner where
i was just
me and and um uh bill joy and rob pike
and it must have been oh boy i don't
know
83 84 something like that
and um uh so bill joy was like we got
the sun workstation
it's this local workstation processing
thing and it's
working with the 68 000 and rob pike was
like
we got this blit terminal and it's this
local
bitmap terminal and the real computation
is happening
on the kind of uh on the sort of
computer power station so to speak i
mean there was this kind of idea
that there would be these kind of
computer power station like things
that would be decentralized computers
have you heard that before yeah
it's so it's funny how history goes in
these cycles
but in any case the um uh that was and
so
at this dinner uh rob and and bill
were kind of you know at each other's
throats
they had some uh kind of i don't know
some other reason for that at that time
but but
um uh arguing you know which is going to
win which is going to win
and i have to say that um at least at
that dinner rob pike made a much better
case for his
his thing than bill joy made for his now
of course history show
you know history went differently uh you
know
bell a t wasn't able to do a good job
licensing
the blit terminal sun microsystems took
off as a business
uh apollo was the other other big player
at that time and companies like hp
philip packard and so on were in the
picture as well
actually an interesting thing that you
know sun and apollo
they had two different approaches so
they both
needed to develop window systems and
what
sun did was they said unix underneath
operating system underneath windows
system on top
apollo had it the other way around they
had a thing called domain i think
where it was like windows system
underneath operating system on top
and turns out that was a bad
architectural decision
because the windows system is a
complicated piece of software
and it was buggy and it remained buggy
for a long time
in the case of sun was the case the
windows crash
you'd dump down into the operating
system apollo
well worst cases the windows crash and
then splat
it's all gone so that was a uh you know
that was a thing that i think was a
sort of distinguishing feature apollo
was a was an east coast based company uh
sun was a west coast based company
um some was the one that won out in the
end in that story
um but i think that the um
the thing i mean it was uh um uh
well at bell labs um rob pike went on to
develop
a thing called cloud nine which was a um
uh an operating system kind of
distributed operating system
um and uh um then
but i think again you know this is a big
challenge for companies
particularly for big companies is how do
you get good ideas out
particularly when you have you know uh
all your businesses are billion dollar
businesses
and there's this little thing that's
starting and it's not going to be a
billion dollar business for a long time
what do you do with it i mean i think um
uh kind of the the
probably the most um uh dramatic example
that's probably xerox park
you know xerox had been this kind of
again kind of a monopoly type company
that had made uh photocopiers and very
successfully so
and they created this palo alto research
center um
and had lots of kind of forward-looking
research done there um but had a very
very very hard time
taking that research and turning it into
something that the xerox corporation
could do things with and in the end for
example our
sort of the notion of window uh windowed
operating systems and so on
that was a xerox park created thing i
mean i remember staying i remember
visiting there
must have been in um um um
maybe 1979 1980 it was the very um
it was this thing was it uh let's see it
was a coyote hill road if i remember
correctly
um and uh in palo alto and it it was a
very um uh kind of it was an intended as
a creative space at the time there were
lots of
you know beanbag chairs and and giant
boards you could write on and things
like that
and um i remember seeing these these
bitmap displays in a color laser printer
um you know never seen one of those
before and they didn't come into common
use for
many many many many years after that um
and i think um
it was some was kind of interesting to
see
uh just a you know a very creative not a
very big place
very creative place generated a lot of
important ideas
um you know i guess uh
i guess ethernet was also um bob metcalf
and someone also
also connected with that if i remember
correctly lots of different people lots
of different ideas
um that didn't really that that you know
it's it's a
it's a big challenging thing i guess i'm
talking about a different topic here
about
more about business and innovation about
kind of how you how you
get new things out in companies that
have existing lines of business
and uh i've i've done a lot of practical
work on that but that's not for here
um all right i think um
um oh okay bcpl apparently stood for
basic combined programming language
that does not help me very much in terms
of its um
its story um
uh yeah you know one of the things to
realize
um uh
oh that's right i'm being reminded it
was plan nine not cloud nine right
plan nine from bell labs um and it uh
i guess um rob pike who has subsequently
gone on to develop
um uh the go programming language
at google rob was i think partly hired
by the
by the promise of having a single letter
um
login um uh you know being early enough
to have a single letter login
um it's uh um uh
at google but but in any case the i'm
sort of amused because
the the same kind of um uh goofy looking
animal you know he has a gopher as the
um
as the logo for the go programming
language same kind of goofy looking
animal
plan nine had a similar kind of goofy
looking animal
um okay well
there's some more questions here about
other programming languages and i'd be
happy to
oh i'll just take one of these from
florida on about did i ever use lisp i
have never used lisp seriously
i've used lisp theoretically a lot
but seriously no i've never used it as
an actual serious programming language
um i knew john mccarthy who is the
creator of lisp
i mean that the story of lisp is um you
know john mccarthy had been interested
in sort of
ai-ish things in the 1950s and um
then uh wanted to kind of come up with a
language that would reflect kind of the
theoretical idea of recursive functions
um and he ended up coming up with
something which is actually much closer
to lambda calculus
although it's not clear to what extent
he had really you know fully ingested
what uh
alonso church had done in the 1930s on
lambda calculus when he invented
lists but kind of in the key papers
about lisp from 1958 and so on
um he's talking about some uh
things some you know lisp s expressions
which are which is
you know which have uh kind of a
you know this kind of tree-like
structure well maybe i shouldn't
start on talking about lists but there's
lots to say about lisp
and about some its development and kind
of um
interesting turns that it took and um
and and perhaps some
i think john mccarthy was always upset
with me for the fact that
when i started developing kind of
symbolic computation systems
they were not built in lisp they were
because at least at the time
it was just a completely impractical uh
system to use
it just didn't have um uh it was
something that was much more of
theoretical relevance than a practical
relevance
there had been back in the in the in the
early 1980s
there were a couple of companies lmi
list machines incorporated and uh
symbolics
which tried to make kind of hardware uh
machines with lisps sort of burnt in as
the hardware
a bunch of interesting ideas did not
work out
as a you know it's kind of a in the
principle software always wins whatever
you can do in software
is going to be more economical than
things that you have to burn into
hardware
at least it's usually true except when
you come to gpus and things like that
where that trend has not um
has not happened by the way i just
should comment this whole uh
as i was sort of making reference to
this whole you know blit versus sun
story of you know the the central
computer versus the local computer
obviously we've seen another iteration
of that with the whole cloud computing
idea
let's go centralized again so it went
you know back
in the um uh in the early days of the
the mainframe um uh computers
you know the ibm 360 the 360 degree
it'll do everything for you
computer uh from the beginning of the
1960s
um that was very much there's a central
computer
everybody uses the central computer
later on there were started to be
time-shared computers where people would
have terminals
that they would interactively inter
interact with but they were
connected by a wire to the central
computer
and and so there was a period of
centralization then the big thing that
happened 1978 to 1980
to 82 84 was personal computers
which initially you know i didn't use a
personal computer for anything serious
until uh the first quotes personal
computer that i used
for anything serious was the next
computer that was in 1989. before that i
had always
used workstation class computers
which i suppose were also personal
computers but they were not really
intended to be bought by individual
people they were
sort of corporate level individual use
computers but
this pendulum has swung back and forth
between sort of central computing
versus local computing and it's really a
complicated trade-off of the speed of
processing
versus the size of software versus the
speed of communication channels
and you know with 5g for example the
pendulum may swing a little bit again
i mean that that will that will probably
again fuel
the idea you know with faster
transmission of things and lower latency
and so on
of uh you know make it more centralized
but then the centralization may be more
locally centralized as in it may be you
know the server in your house
not the server at the cloud providers
and so on but anyway
uh much to say about that uh all right
people are asking about um i need to
talk about lisp all right so next time
i'll
i'll
uh i'll make sure to talk about that um
all right a lot of a lot of other
interesting questions came in here
um i look forward to addressing them
another time i should wrap up for now
here
i think i have to go back to my day job
and actually i'm doing another live
stream about software design
in about seven minutes
so thanks for joining me here
and